so would it be fair to say that you have
not
have you rendered any
opinions in this case as an expert
witness based on publicly available
records i have not rendered any opinion
based on any publicly available records
thank you
now you were asked a number of questions
about narcissistic traits and your diet
your diagnosis or findings that mr depp
exhibited narcissistic traits or had
that disorder do you recall that
testimony yes all right and
uh the question was asked of you of the
uh whether if you have five of nine
narcissistic traits do you remember that
testimony yes okay now one of the ones
you testified before was in for
narcissism it requires admiration
correct yes
what if any record evidence was there
that mr depp requires admiration
the the very people that surround him
need to admire him or they're no longer
in his employment or his uh working
circle okay the second one that you
discussed was sense of entitlement do
you recall that testimony yes all right
what record evidence is there that mr
depp exhibited exhibits behavior of
needing a sense of entitlement
so again thinking that uh miss heard
was marrying him solely for his money
and his influence and that
that was the case
was in my opinion very entitled
all right and the third one you
discussed was exploitative do you recall
that yes okay and what is the record
evidence that mr depp exhibits behaviors
of ex that are exploitative again i
think the whole concept of abuse is
exploitative i'm just going to ask you
to
give the record evidence of
mr depp's uh lacking empathy that you
know of yes
my lab am i a lot elaborate yes just
just a little different than what you
said before okay
um
so
if
if one does so i'll make it more direct
so if you're not agreeing with what mr
depp has to say
you are no longer useful okay therefore
you don't really care about others for
others you care about others for your
benefit so
often on dismissing dr kipper
for dr kipper setting some boundaries on
substance use protocol substance detox
is an example of lacking empathy and not
really caring what other people have to
say
all right another one of the
characteristics that you cited was
envious do you recall that testimony yes
what is the record evidence that mr depp
exhibits envy
i think jealousy is a good start for
that i i think that miss her wanting to
have a career start with that beyond
what she has uh and the the jealousy
parts of with mr franco and
um
i think others the uh comment this week
was bursting sorry last week ms burstin
commented about things about jealousy so
i think it's pretty apparent
okay
and the next one you listed was fragile
self-esteem do you recall that
yeah and what is the record evidence of
mr dev exhibiting that so fragile
self-esteem would be more along the line
of a cluster b trait i should put that
as not necessarily the criteria for
narcissism so it's a trait
and basically what that means will be
that the
combination of
poor self-control and rapid mood states
is fragile
self-esteem fragile personality so
trades so go in the line of cluster b
rather than per se narcissistic